this is definitely the longest I've ever
touched my nipple in front of a camera
but not by much hey look beautiful I'm
very excited about this experience I
guess pasties are like a thing you wear
when you don't want to wear clothes but
it's illegal to share your nipples just
from like how curved this is I don't
know if it's gonna be able to reach my
nipple well when I grew to do this as I
was pastries so actually thought I was
going to be eating stuff so I'm kind of
more nervous I'm really excited about
this experience let's get my nips ready
so let's put glue around the outside but
not in the center so that I don't rip
off my nipples now I do have a third
nipple so do I need like three I have to
take some of this and then tease myself
a little bit by putting on my nipple
there been any like emergency room
reports of how often people accidentally
rip up their nipples with pasties if you
use the wrong glue never been a guy who
really touches nipples a lot but like
hands are just like yeah those like
little half samurais would wear and then
kind of like just like the one
it's got like a nice like pirate feel I
can barely articulate words give that's
how embarrassed I am right now I don't
really feel like this does a great job
of covering up the nipples if anything
it just draws attention to the nipples
so I mean I I would use this I feel like
this is kind of like to feel safer
what's so terrible about a nipple
they're kind of weird-looking but
everybody's got them just got to drop it
right
I'm um you loo I'm not dancing I think
it's weird that there's such a taboo
against freely shown nipples that we had
to invent a device specifically designed
to be glued on them to cover them I feel
sexy yeah like I can move I can move
around if you let guys show their
nipples and how come you don't let girls
show their nipples I want to celebrate
my chest area but as far as covering up
or feel ashamed of it this does not help
at all